TO BE CONTINUED.
MY GUESS IS WE’RE DEBATING THE
SAME THING.
>> Dana: CHICAGO TEACHERS UNION
MEMBERS ARE VOTING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK FROM HOME DUE TO
CORONAVIRUS SAFETY CONCERNS.
THIS MOVE GOES AGAINST THE
CITY’S PLAN TO REOPEN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS FOR IN-PERSON LEARNING.
GARRETT TENNEY IS LIVE IN
CHICAGO.
WHAT HAPPENS TO CLASSES THIS
WEEK IF TEACHERS DON’T SHOW UP?
>> WELL DANA, THE UNION SAID IF
CHICAGO PUBLIC SCHOOLS TRIES TO
FORCE ITS TEACHERS BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM, THEY WILL GO ON
STRIKE.
SCHOOLS ARE SCHEDULED TO REOPEN
TO IN-PERSON LEARNING A WEEK
FROM TODAY.
THE DISTRICT ORDERED TEACHERS
TO BE IN THEIR PHYSICAL
CLASSROOM THIS WEEK TO GET
READY TO WELCOME STUDENTS BACK.
71% VOTED TO REJECT THE
DISTRICT’S DEMAND.
AFTER THE VOTE THE UNION
PRESIDENT SAID THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE
CHOSEN, SAFETY, UNITY AND
SOLIDARITY AND AN AGREEMENT IS
WITHIN REACH BUT WE NEED A
WILLING PARTNER.
THE UNION DOESN’T WANT TO
RETURN TO IN-PERSON LEARNING
UNTIL ALL TEACHERS ARE
VACCINATED DESPITE LOCAL, STATE
AND FEDERAL HEALTH OFFICIALS
SAYING SCHOOLS CAN OPERATE
SAFELY WITH APPROPRIATE
PRECAUTIONS IN PLACE.
CPS SAYS GRADES, ATTENDANCE AND
ENROLLMENT HAS DROPPED
SIGNIFICANTLY FOR STUDENTS OVER
THE PAST FEW MONTHS AND NEED TO
BE BACK IN THE CLASSROOM TO
KEEP THINGS ARE GETTING WORSE.
MANY PARENTS AND STUDENTS AGREE.
>> THEY HAVE ALL ASKED AND THAT
IS NOT TYPICAL FOR MY CHILDREN.
IMSEEING INCREASING ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION IN ALL THREE OF MY
CHILDREN.
THE STRIKE FOR THESE VULNERABLE
CHILDREN IS TRAUMATIZING AND
WILL IMPACT THEIR EDUCATION AND
MENTAL HEALTH.
>> I NEED A BREAK FROM MY MOM.
I JUST NEED TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL.
>> Bill: THE COVID SITUATION IN
CHICAGO HAS BEEN STEADILY
IMPROVING.
THIS WEEKEND RESTAURANTS
REOPENED FOR INDOOR DINING AND
STARTING TODAY TEACHERS IN
ILLINOIS ARE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE THE FIRST DOSE OF THE
VACCINE.
SO FAR BOTH THE CHICAGO
TEACHERS UNION AND CHICAGO
PUBLIC SCHOOLS SAY NEGOTIATIONS
ARE ONGOING.
BUT IF NO DEAL IS REACHED BY
WEDNESDAY TEACHERS COULD
OFFICIALLY GO ON STRIKE.
DANA.